so what would a 4D object look like to
us well it depends what part of that 4D
object is passing through our 3D space
I've received word that a 4D ball is
about to pass through our world please
stand by right now we can see a small
sphere because this slice is near the
edge of the 40 ball it grows in size as
it moves through our world and right now
we see it as its largest because this
slice is at the middle of the 40 ball it
shrinks again as it continues to move
through our world and now we don't see
it the 4D ball still exists but our
slice of space does not contain it a 4D
creature would still see the ball and
know exactly where it is but we are not
gifted that kind of perspective